foreign
[Music]
well no I guess this isn't what you
signed up for when you decided to be a
famous actor is it it's not my fault I
never wanted to be famous
sorry kiddo that's not the way I
remember it but I didn't want to be
famous I wanted to go to school hey it's
true
all of those people cheering and
applauding I hated it
what's happening Jiminy
looks like some sort of fairy magic
kind of on the nose if you ask me but
the point is a lie can really change a
person pinocs we just why I'm telling
you the 100
honest truthiest truthiness ever believe
me
oops okay that last part wasn't true but
everything I said
Ben what
Jiminy you okay more or less now quit
telling those Whoppers
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
I present to you
the eighth wonder of the world
[Music]
the one and only
[Music]
[Applause]
hello Pops
jumping Keepers and almost real boy
[Music]
turn around let me get a look at you
[Music]
get back
Pinocchio is running around loose
without a conscience can you imagine the
trouble he's gonna get into wouldn't
want that on my conscience everybody
who's anybody who wants to be a somebody
that I want to be real why on Earth
would you want to be real when you can
be famous
[Music]
okay we should have been home by now
he won't be a puppet anymore
that's for sure
[Music]
be brave
truthful not selfish
[Music]
you will always be my real boy
a lie can really change a person panops
what's happening Jiminy looks like some
sort of fairy magic
kinda on the nose if you ask me
[Music]